Asia, his young wife, his child bride,
uh, who I believe married when she was
nine, though he had possession of her
when she was six. What we would call
then it would be normal. Oh, I'm a
Muslim man. I'm 30. I'm 40 and I'm going
to marry a 9-year-old. You can have four
wives and as many slaves as you want,
concubines. And they talk about how they
attacked and killed everyone and they
took a nun and gang her until she died
in front of everyone. And the eyewitness
says, "And the Turks did this often to
pilgrims." Jihad of the pen. jihad of
the tongue, jihad of the money, jihad of
the womb. And all of them are to serve
Islam to empower it over infidels. And
the Muslim is one who submits. But if
you really went to it, it was a
political thing. I'm superior. I'm the
warlord. You're joining me. You're
submitting to me in what I say, which
comes from God. And that was it. He
claims he's from God. But his modus
operendi, the way he behaves is all
about violence, warfare, plunder, you
know, sexuality, you know, concubinage,
etc. England, it's reached the point
where you can't even say the truth about
what's happening without going to jail.
So, obviously, the rulers of England,
whether they are British natives, hate
and are waring on their own
[Music]
people. Remed is an American author,
historian, and public speaker. He was
born in the United States to Coptic
Christian parents from Egypt. Ibrahim
holds a bachelor's degree and a master's
degree in history from California State
University, Fresno with a focus on
Islamic and Middle Eastern history. He
also studied at Georgetown University
Center for Contemporary Arab Studies.
From 2006 to 2010, he worked as an
Arabic language researcher at the
Library of Congress. He's an author of
four books. The al-Qaeda reader,
Crucified Again, Crucified Again, Sword
and Skimar, which we have right here,
and the newest book is uh The Defenders
of the West. Correct. Yeah. Defender of
the West. Rams speaks three languages,
English, Arabic, and Greek. His language
skills, particularly in Arabic, have
played a central ro role in his work,
especially in translating jihadist text
for his book, The Al-Qaeda Reader. His
writings have appeared in various
publications including the Middle East
Quarterly, National Review, and the
Washington Times. He's a frequent guest
on media outlets and has delivered
lectures and briefings to government and
academic academic institutions. Mr.
Behim is a man of God. Welcome to the
show. Thank you, Apollo. Very good to be
with you. So, a quick story of mine. So,
just as I told you, I was baptized when
I was only 6 months old and I was
baptized to this name Apollinario, which
is Apollo. So I was I'm 37 years old.
For 35 years I was u an atheist though I
was baptized. My family my family has
never been religious. We always
celebrated Easter and Christmas but I
knew that this is has something to do
with with Jesus but nothing nothing
more. Once I came here to the US I was
like so Christianity is not about being
a Catholic. So the you don't recognize
here in the US papacy the pope it means
nothing to you. you only read scripture
and if it's if it's written in the
scripture it means this is the truth. So
no traditions of Catholics or orthodox.
So the main reason I'm here uh sitting
right in front of you is because I am
from Lithuania. So my country is very
old country. So the first time Lithuania
is mentioned in the history is 2000
109th year. Right? So my country has be
has uh become a Christian country. she
the country was baptized I want to say
in 13
1387 and once and uh since from my
childhood I remember in the school I was
taught like this great duke he baptized
our country he became a king and etc and
I was like why and I always wanted to
know how and what were what were the u
terms and conditions kind of of getting
baptized as a whole as a country so
today I would like would love to talk to
you about Christianity, Islam, Islamism
and the great crusades just like the
third the fourth your book defenders of
the west is all about. Yeah. So let's
set the stage. Let's say we're in the
year
approximately 33rd year after the Jesus
Christ was born. So he's being
crucified, right? What's the state in
the world? So the whole world is
basically what? Asia and Europe, right?
Middle East. What do we see outside?
What kind of world we live in? If it's
AD.33,
the world is Rome. This is the Roman
Empire at the point. The world that is
known that Western civilization traces
its its its heritage to is Rome. And it
is a big chunk of the real world. Of
course, you have the Americas, North and
South Americas, and you have indigenous
peoples living there, but we have no
written records of history there. So, we
can't really trace it. So civilized
empire is Rome. Yes, you have the east,
you have China, you have India, you have
the peoples living there, but the main
peoples that we think of which today
would correspond with Middle Eastern
people, um European people, North
Africans and of course Europe, you know,
even all the way up to Germania and
people in the Britons or English people.
Now all this was Rome. So you really
that that's the best way to understand
it without in a simple way. Of course,
I'm saying there are other peoples or
subsaharans and so forth, but recorded
history is primarily um limited to what
is the Roman Empire. And so Jesus and
the events you're discussing 33 AD is
squarely situated in that context. So
AD33 out of 100% of people that live on
the earth, let's say that live in the
Roman Empire, percentage wise, how many
of them are pagans still? When Jesus is
crucified, all of them except his
disciples. Well, yeah. But Jews, they
were Oh. Oh. Oh, I thought you meant
Christians. The Jews are still, of
course, you have the Jews um in 33 AD.
But the followers of Christ are just
basically his disciples at the day of
his crucifixion and maybe others,
hundreds of others or whatever the
number may be. And you have the Jews. I
can't give you a number, but of course,
the Jews themselves are a very tiny
minority and all limited to Judea at the
time. Um, so I mean I would say not even
probably a percent because of the Roman
Empire when you realize it's all of
Europe and North Africa and the Middle
East. They're all pagans. Yeah. Yeah.
Like the pagan Romans uh worshiping your
namesake
Apollo and uh you know Zeus and all that
sort of thing. Well, it's now Roman, but
it's the same Greek gods under different
names. You know, Saturn and and Zeus and
uh so forth. Um but yeah, all pagans. So
in 610 something happens right prior to
610 what were the major historic events
that we can discuss just to get to lay
the foundation to what happened in
610 sure there's a lot of things going
on you know of course we just mentioned
Jesus um you have it's still the Roman
Empire you have the destruction of
Jerusalem um you know 70 AD and then
again I want to say around 112
uh there's another rebellion um from
Jews and then it's completely the the
diaspora comes at this point where the
Jews are completely exiled um and uh
it's it's completely turned into an
absolute Roman territory. So this is
another highlight. Um the main then it
still remains a pagan uh time and this
is the great era of persecution of
Christians under various Roman emperors.
Diolesian for example, Nero before him
at the time of Peter and Paul. Um and
then you know you fast forward until you
finally the persecutions continue. Some
of the worst actually under Dialesian
were in Egypt. Um which I find
interesting because I'm of Egyptian
Coptic heritage and they're still being
persecuted. you know, they're still
amongst the worst who are persecuted by
Muslims till this day. So, it's kind of
interesting with Egypt, but all
throughout the Middle East or as we
would call it today until the rise of
Constant Constantine the Great, you
know, and uh who becomes the first
Christian emperor and even before he
becomes Christian, he um the edict of
Milan, it really introduces religious
freedom. So, you can be a Christian
without being persecuted now or you can
be a pagan. So it's a time of religious
toleration under Constantine. And then
he also, you know, makes a pivotal move.
He moves the Roman Empire uh which is
important actually to the our story from
Rome to the east um to an area a little
a little Greek settlement that was known
as Bzantium, but it was a very well
fortified city. So he built his new Nova
Roma, new Rome, but we know it today as
Constantinople or rather as Istanbul
today. Turkey. Yeah. And uh so that's a
very pivotal event. Constantine is very
important during this time under his uh
leadership also the holy land now okay
so it's been expuned of Jews way earlier
and it's part of the Christian empire of
of Constantine and uh especially under
his mother Helena is when they find you
know according to the teachings and the
traditions of Catholics and Orthodox
they find the um important sites of
Christendom the burial of Christ where
he was resurrected uh the the the site
of the crucifiction iction and
supposedly they find uh as it's known
throughout history the true cross which
is supposedly the cross that Christ
himself was crucified on and um they
build a massive basilica in Jerusalem
over all those sites which becomes known
as the holy supple um or the church of
the resurrection it's a massive complex
essentially it's a basilica over all
those sites and it's very important to
our story as we'll see that's why I
mention it so okay so you have
Constantine Christian persecution ends.
Now we're in the 300s. There's a time
under Julian the apostate who's a
descendant of Constantine, I think a
nephew, and he becomes emperor and he
tries to bring paganism back, but it
doesn't work. It's ultimately it failed
and people just now are becoming
Christians. So by the fourth, you know,
the fourth century and the fifth
century, Europe and and the Middle East
is heavily heavily Christian. Egypt and
all those countries, the Middle East,
Syria, Armenia, of course, is the first
Christian nation to adopt the religion
uh formally and officially, but all
throughout North Africa, all throughout
Europe, paganism dies. Okay? So, and
then you fast forward to the time of
Muhammad who's born uh supposedly in 570
AD. And at this time, what's going on is
you have the Christian world, which is
still Rome. And um but you also have the
rise you've always had Persians and they
were the Zorastrians. They have their
own very distinct uh sophisticated
culture and philosophy and religion and
civilization. And um they're waring with
Rome. So Christian Rome is at war with
Ceanian. That's the name of the empire,
Persia, which is a Zorastrian empire.
And they just they worship fire, right?
Yeah. The Zarastrians. Yeah. loosely
speaking but at this point they may have
more of a manakian element which is a
sort of a dualism which also accords
with zorastrianism but pagans
essentially from a Christian point of
view they would be and they war with the
Christian empire and there's very
graphic very graphic accounts of they
sack Jerusalem which was of course like
I said the pivotal point since
Constantine's time of christendom and
they they steal the true cross there's a
lot of big saga about what they did and
then you The emperor Heraclus brings it
back and at that time Jerusalem belongs
to the Roman Empire. Yeah. But it gets
conquered by the Persians for something
like 10 years and they commit all sorts
of atrocities uh against the Christians
and against the churches etc etc. This
is the backdrop. Uh this is going on
while Muhammad is actually alive and
preaching
in Saudi in well Arabia at the time. And
um so this is the backdrop. Okay, if you
fast forward to the times of uh of when
Muhammad now is alive and um he's
preaching his message and you know,
yeah, 610 he's this is now he's in Mecca
and he's preaching and he's he still
hasn't done the higra in 622 where he
year one of the Islamic calendar and so
I'll stop there. So 610 and you said
622, right? Mhm. Why do you think in
your opinion Islam occurred in the first
place? Was it a political move? Why did
it occur? and what happened in that time
period of time. Sure. And before I
answer that, I I'll point out something
that there's been this massive attack on
the historioggraphy, the traditional
historioggraphy of Islam's origins. Um,
but I'm more of a traditionalist. In
other words, what I'm trying to say is
there's people today who will have you
believe Muhammad didn't even exist and
they have a whole complete revisionist
history. Um, which I reject. And I only
say this as a as a prelude to what I
will say. I I and and at the same time I
only accept the barebone basic
understanding of Muhammad's rise. In
other words, I can give you the Islamic
traditional story, what Muslims believe
or I can tell you uh what I believe,
which is a simplified version. It's a
more, you know, it's the barebone what
we need to know about. We we know what
Muslims believe in. So I would like to
hear the barebone version is there's a
man who rose in Arabia during this time
that we're talking about let's say in
the early 600s who said he's a prophet
from God and he basically uh his message
was a sort of synchronetic Christian
Jewish message focused on monotheism
which was revolutionary for the Arabians
because they were pagans and
polytheists. Um and um his career goes,
you know, uh it goes from being
outnumbered and weak and he has no
followers and he just preaches peace
till he gains followers and the more he
becomes stronger then the more he goes
on the offensive until uh basically he
becomes uh and this is the idea of jihad
and this is actually so the revelations
of the Quran the Quran as we have it
today is believed to be revealed to
Muhammad by the angel Gabriel peace meal
Okay. Over various years all and and
it's put together now. And um so based
on the circumstances of what Muhammad
was experiencing, um Gabriel through
Allah revealed the Quran to him. And
like I said, it starts off, excuse me,
starts off, you know, just preaching
peace. Then he becomes strong. And long
story short, it ends up preaching war,
offensive war against everyone until
they submit to Allah and Muhammad. So
the word Muslim, Muslim we say but in
Arabic Muslim and Islam, Islam they just
mean submission. So in its origin he was
really a political leader. He was not a
religious leader. To be a Muslim Islam
means submit. Submit to what? Submit to
my authority. I'm Muhammad. I'm the
ruler and yeah behind me is Allah God.
So you're submitting to God. That's the
Hegioraphical version, right? And the
Muslim is one who submits. So it was a
purely political thing. You know if you
actually went down to the time when this
was happening. So today
Islamic historioggraphy or rather
heography presents it in a in a
religious terminology. But if you really
went to it, it was a political thing.
I'm superior. I'm the warlord. You're
joining me. You're submitting to me in
what I say which comes from God. And
that was it. Nobody cared. In other
words, Muhammad didn't care about the
condition of the convert's heart. Okay?
It was just about political submission.
Submit. Believe what you want. Just do
what we say and agree with what we say,
which is there's one God. I'm his
prophet and what I say goes. That was
it. Okay. So, so as a Christian, do you
believe that our angel Gabriel is the
same angel as they say Gabriel? Right.
In Gabriel. Yeah. No. No. No. Of course.
as a Christian. So even the earliest
Christians who understood the story of
Muhammad and near contemporaries such as
John of Damascus you know who was born
maybe 70 years after Muhammad's life um
they actually believed that it was
either it was a demon okay it was a
genie some Muhammad himself according to
the Islamic tradition this Gabriel would
come and choke him and he would have
epileptic seizures and it was violence
and you would like embrace and hug him
and almost kill him and Muhammad himself
according to the Islamic record was
afraid of this until he told his wife
Khadijah and she told him no that's the
angel of God you know something like
that so even even in the Islamic record
it comes out that this was a strange
supernatural being but then it ends up
it's it's Gabriel but it's written in
the Quran or the in the hadiths it's
primarily in the hadith most of what we
know about the Muhammad's life is the
hadith and the sir the s is the
biography by hack um but also the hadith
They're very similar. The hadith is just
peace meal various sayings and doings of
Muhammad and the sir is more of a
chronological narrative but they
coincide but most of what we know really
if if it was just based on the Quran
it's a very incoherent mostly poetic uh
work in Arabic which would be very
confusing which is really why Muslims
need the need the hadith and need the s
because if it was just the Quran it's
very hard to make sense of it and you
can interpret it in various ways. This
is why Sunnis turn to the Sunnah which
is the hadith and the example and the S.
So yeah, most of what we're talking
about really traces to those sources.
Tell me about Muhammad, what kind of man
he was. What does history tell us about
this man? So it's interesting because I
just did an actually deep dive in this
and it's what I find fascinating is we
have very early records of Muhammad from
non-Muslim sources. The earliest is 2
years after his death. And you know,
just to put it to put this in
perspective, the earliest non-Christian
uh uh reference to Jesus is 60 years
after his death or crucifixion. Okay, so
2 years, that's really good. And what it
is is basically a record of people
saying that a man arose in Arabia saying
he's a prophet, but people don't believe
him because prophets who all they have
their claim to fame is just bloodshed
and war are not real prophets. Okay? and
and the same account talks about how he
promises heaven to his followers. So if
you really look at the very early
non-Muslim sources especially, they all
make it unequivocally clear there's a
man whose name or his title is Muhammad
the praised one and he claims he's from
God but his modus operendi the way he
behaves is all about violence, warfare,
plunder, you know, sexuality, you know,
concubinage, etc. Um, and you know, if
you die, you go to heaven. And even in
his time, there's a lot of people who
doubt him. Okay. So, that's to me the
barebone minimum understanding of
Muhammad based on very reliable
contemporary records. How many wives did
he have? Well, so according to he had I
I think I want to say nine or 10, which
is more than what any Muslim man should
have. A Muslim man should have four. But
of course he always new new revelations
would come to him which would justify
more license to him sexually. His own
wife Aisha his young wife his child
bride uh who I believe married when she
was nine though he had possession of her
when she was six. Um there is in the
hadith where she says I find it amazing
how your Lord Allah always reveals
things that you need right when you need
them because he was given a license to
have more wives than every other Muslim
man. So you know even in the sources it
comes out that there's a lot of cynicism
towards what he's doing. What do Muslims
say when they hear that their main
prophet Muhammad had a 6 to9 yearear-old
wife? That just how do they justify it?
It's they it's not that they justify it.
They see it as they've just now been
given license to do the same in Iraq
everywhere actually. uh you know I mean
yes in Iraq it's now becoming actually
part of the law but historically because
Muhammad did that that's why you had
basically ped what we would call
pedophilia but then it would be normal
oh I'm a Muslim man I'm 30 I'm 40 and
I'm going to marry a nine-year-old
because Muhammad was 50 plus when she
married Asia and she was nine we met him
six married when she was nine why do you
think Islam succeeded in the first place
because he kind of uh that was kind of
Christianity but a little bit tweaked
You can have more wives, right? Four
wives. That's amazing for a male, right?
So, why did Islam succeed in the first
place? Well, there it is. It's not just
you can have it's a very male ccentric
religion. It's trying to gratify the
male because it's not even four wives.
You can have four wives and as many sex
slaves as you want, concubines. That's
according to the Quran to that is in the
Quran. Quran. That's holy. Yes, it's
holy. They're called in Arabic melt aum
which means So, the verses that say you
can have four wives, they usually say I
think I want to say 43. Chapter 4 3 is
one of them but there's others but it
says you know you can have as many as
four wives and aum that which your right
hand possesses which according to
Islamic exedites means uh that you know
females who female infidels that have
been conquered in war sex slaves
limitless number as far as why it became
so popular I think that's one of the
reasons because it really gratified the
most basic and primordial urges of men
it's said now and this is actually why
It became very popular amongst tribal
peoples, Arabs and then later Turks,
pastoral tribal peoples and later
Mongols, Berbers as well. It never
really settled or you know became a it
didn't resonate with sedentry civilized
people. It was always nomadic people.
And the reason is because those people
were already tribal. To be tribal meant
it's us against everyone else. Everyone
else is the enemy and it's our duty to
attack them, kill them, um enslave them,
plunder them. Okay, that is good.
So Muhammad's genius, if you will, is
that he took the same tribal mores of
his society, 7th century Arabia, but
rearticulated them in a uh the
theological paradigm. So now it wasn't
just so from I attack it's us against
them. Now it became yes, it's us against
them. But them, us was no longer the
blood tribe. It was the Muslims, the
Muslims, and them was the non-Muslims.
even if they are blood relatives. So
even the Quran says if you have to hate
and war upon and distance yourself from
your father, your mother, your brother,
your sister, if they're not your sons,
your whatever if they're not Muslims,
they're the enemy. Quran says so. Yes, I
can if we have time, I can pull out the
verse for you. I think it's 64 is the
main one. And it says you I'm
paraphrasing, but it says you have a
good example in Abraham. Ibraim, Abraham
of the Old Testament, Ibrahim to them.
Uh because so the Genesis account of
Abraham, God calls him out and you know
he leaves the pagan world that he's in
and he goes and finds the new nation of
Israel. Uh in the Muslim account, he
does the same thing, but he also tells
his former formal family and tribe that
we hate you. Enmity shall last forever
between us until you believe in Allah
alone. So that has sort of become
articulated and codified in Islamic
worldview. It's actually part of a
doctrine
called which uh I can I usually
translate as loyalty and enmity or love
and hate. And it basically means you
have to love and be close to Muslims. It
has nothing to do with blood and you
have to hate non-Muslims even if they're
your relatives. Okay. So Allah in the
Quran has 99 names. Correct. Yeah. I
don't know if it's in the Quran. Yeah, I
think it is in the Quran but yeah. Can
you name me at least 10? because I was
doing a podcast with the Imam. He
couldn't tell me at least three of them.
The ones 99 names. Yeah. Yeah. The
compassionate, the merciful. Um, you
know, I've seen them all, but the ones
that stick in my mind are usually the
ones that are unflattering. He's also
the Makar, which means he's the
deceiver. Okay. He's the master of he's
the ma. Yeah, he's he's everything. I I
can't name them like the imam. I've seen
them. I've encountered them. Um, but
they're all sorts of names. The only
ones I remember are the ones that you
would think are controversial. And the
main one that's always pointed out is
the Makar, which means the deceiver, the
trickster. He's like a Loki figure
almost amongst Muslims. But in the
Bible, the father of lies is who? Satan.
Yeah. Why? Why in the Quran Jesus
included? And why do they praise him?
The Muslim kind of love Jesus, right?
Well, yeah. Yes or no? What it is is so
Islam is the new religion, right? Is
Muhammad comes and Judaism exists,
Christianity exists. The two are tied
together, right? Jesus is a Jew. The New
Testament talks about the Old Testament.
You know, there's a continuity in there.
And then you have the this Arab guy in
in Arabia. So what Muhammad did is he
appropriated to give legitimacy to his
movement. He had to connect himself to
Judaism, Christianity because that's
what everyone knew. That is the those
are the traditional names that that have
the weight of antiquity. Abraham, Moses,
Jesus. So who's this guy name? Yeah. So
he has to bring them in. So what he did
is he used them and he said, "Yeah, of
course they're all true and we love
them." But he recast them and made them
such so that they were basically
promoting with him. So basically Jesus
was came to earth primarily to tell us
about the pariclete and the paricletes
the holy spirit but it's a Greek word
which means the comforter. According to
Muslims the comforter is Muhammad. So
Jesus came to proclaim Muhammad and
everything was turned around. So yes
Abraham is good and he's a prophet and
and everyone's a prophet. Jesus is a
prophet. So, Muslims believe a lot of
the people who want you to, you know,
think that there's a, you know, dialogue
or there's some sort of commonality
between Muslims and Christians say what
you just said. You know, they love
Jesus. They believe he was born of a
virgin, that he was sinless, that he was
perfect, that he performed miracles.
That all sounds great, but they reject
the cardinal teachings of Christ. They
reject he's the son of God. They reject
he was crucified. They reject he was
resurrected. He didn't die for mankind's
sin. So the really important things that
they reject but again it's always taking
them to give themselves some sort of
legitimacy and saying yes we're part of
that old ancient heritage of Judaism
Christianity but then they are rewritten
in a different way which is very
different incidentally from what
Christians do. So obviously Christians
and Jews are very are different because
Christians believe in Christ and Jews
don't. Um, but what's interesting is
Christians took what we call the Old
Testament, the Jewish scriptures as they
are. So if you look at the Bible, right,
and you have the Old Testament, that is
the same books that the Jews have to.
Yeah. Yeah. From Genesis all the way to,
I think, Malachi or Okay. They have the
same books and the Christians did not
change them. Now they may Christians
have their own interpretation. So
Abraham now is no longer the father of
Israel is now Christians. So there's
interpretational changes, but the text
is the same. What Muhammad did and what
Muslims do is completely different. Is
they said the Old Testament and the New
Testament, the way it's written is
wrong. And Muhammad is here to give us
the new version. So he claims them, but
he changes who they are and what they
said. So Jesus, um, like I said, he's
actually a prophet, and he's here to
proclaim the same thing that Muhammad
is. And when he comes back on
resurrection day, and he will uh he's
going to break all the crosses and kill
all the pigs because uh he's like
Muhammad and that's all. So you see it's
all rewritten in a way to validate
Islam. All right. So in Islam, Jesus
when he comes back for the second time,
he's he's going to judge. Yeah. So if
they say that Jesus is not the son of
God and he is not the God himself, then
how can he judge on the judgment day? If
only God can judge. I may I may not be
correct about if he's going to judge,
but he's known to be part of the
judgment day. He's part of es the is,
you know, the Islamic esquetology end
days. Um, but his exact role, like I
said, primarily it's to tell Christians
how they are wrong. So he's going to
break the cross. He's going to kill the
pigs and he's going to cancel Jiza. Jiz
was the way Christians could remain
Christians is they pay tribute. So now
by cancelelling Jiz means you can't even
you can't even be a Christian. You have
to become a true Muslim because Jesus is
a Muslim in the Islamic rendering Isa.
But as far the as the judgment issue,
I'm not really sure. What's the problem
with the pigs?
I don't know. Muhammad didn't dig on
swine. So I mean maybe it goes back to
Judaism. A lot of he is Islam
appropriated a lot of Jewish things. And
I know the pig isn't popular. It's not
kosher amongst the Jews. So it may be he
was copying that as well. But yeah, what
about dogs? Muslim Muslims cannot have
dogs, right? Yeah. They're not supposed
to. Muhammad says if a househ if a
household has a dog, angels will not
visit it. And so until this very day,
dogs are really mistreated from a humane
point of view. And it comes I actually
wrote an article about it very recently.
Um and it goes back to a hadith where
Muhammad hated dogs. And in some
countries they'll just kill them
outright because of dogs only cats. He
actually liked cats. So amongst Muslims
cats are approvable. You can have a cat
because Muhammad liked cats and cats
were worshiped basically in Egypt.
Correct. Yeah. Yeah. That's pre-Islamic.
So I don't know if there's any
connection but yeah he liked cats
apparently. So what happens prior to
1096 prior to the first crusade and
because once I was in school let's say
third fourth fifth grade I was told
though although Lithuania is a very
Christian country Catholic country but I
was told that the the crusades were
horrible incident incidents innocent
people were killed slaughtered raped and
etc. Right. your the country you come
from and Estonia and those sort of
Baltic regions don't like the crusades
because um they were Christianized in
parts of those crusades including at the
hands of the um Tutonic Knights um a
military order a Catholic military
order. So the original crusades had
nothing to do with that. It was against
Islam and uh the very first crusade
which was called in 1095 was completely
against Muslims because they were
persecuting and horrifically killing
Christians and destroying churches. And
going back now to Constantine and the
holy seleure in Jerusalem which was a
pilgrimage site since the before
Constantine but especially after
Constantine and it continued being a
pilgrimage site um uh even after the
Muslim conquest of the holy land around
637. Um but and and Christians would
suffer and they had to pay taxes.
Sometimes it would be attacked and
killed by Muslims, but they still would
go. It was a sacrifice because holy
sites were very important back in those
days. Um so that goes on uh I'm just
going a little before the first crusade.
And then by the time of uh you know
around 900 or a thousand, the Turks
start rising and they become a very
dominant force in the Islamic world. And
they're Muslims. They were originally
imported as uh slave soldiers by the
caliphates, especially the Abbassad
caliphate at that time. And they would
bring these Turk warriors and convert
them to Islam and they became the
greatest warriors. And then before you
know it, they actually became the
standard bearers of jihad and the Arabs
time waines and really the caliphate is
a public is a puppet figure, the
Abbassad caliphate which the Turks keep,
but they're in charge. they're in power
and under them the first dynasty really
is well not the first but the the more
dominant one is the Seljic Turks and uh
they start attacking uh Asia Minor in
around the middle of the 11th century
1050 and very horrific the bloodshed is
just mindboggling as it's recorded in
the sources especially of Armenians
because Armenians are a large nation at
this time in Asia Minor but also as they
go later further in against Greeks and
so forth um and the records you know
Matthew of Adessa says a chronicler
who's a New York contemporary. He talks
about tens of thousands of Christians
being massacred, even more enslaved just
because they refused to convert. Yeah.
By the Turks and churches ritually
desecrated and destroyed in one city,
Ani, which was the capital at the time
of Armenia. It was known as the city of
a thousand1 churches. They were all
burned and destroyed all the and and a
large crucifix was sent to Baghdad as a
trophy of war. again underscoring the
ideological aspect to this. Um and also
the pilgrims who were going to the holy
land to see the holy
sele. One of the more famous and
horrific instances was a large German
pilgrimage which was in 1064 1065 and
they talk about how they attacked and
killed everyone and they took a nun and
gang raped her until she died in front
of everyone. And the eyewitness says,
"And the Turks did this often to
pilgrims." And that's what gave rise to
the first crusade in 1095 just to pre
the horror, just the sheer horror and
attacks on Christians. And so Pope Urban
II in 1095 in part responding to the
Roman Emperor Alexius who was now under
because all these were formerly Eastern
Roman Byzantine territories. So he asked
for aid from the west and he described
what was happening and that's exactly
what Pope Urban and all the other uh you
know preachers of the first crusade were
talking about which is what was
happening to Christians what was
happening to the holy land what was
happening to pilgrims and that was the
the rise of the first crusade. It was a
noble venture. It was altruistic. It was
about actually writing wrongs. They
actually would quote the verse that you
know no greater love does a man have
than to lay down his life for his fellow
man and that's what they were doing and
all and also in the context of you know
loving God and loving your fellow man.
So loving your fellow man was going on a
crusade to help eastern Christians
loving God was going to go and uh
liberate the holy land Jerusalem because
they were mocking. So in 109 which is
even way before
1095 one khif the holy suppleure the
large massive complex that Constantine
built was he destroyed it he completely
destroyed it plundered it and he
destroyed 30,000 other churches
according to Muslim sources most western
historians don't say this they say
30,000 30,000 and most western
historians will put the number 300 or
3,000 and they'll say oh that's a
scribal error the Muslims are wrong but
it's a Muslim it's al-makzi it's an um
Egyptian historian. So they were not
boast just boasting and telling the
truth. Yeah. And it's a reflection of
how Christian that region was because
before the Islamic conquest even in 1009
that's only 400 years later it was still
a very very heavily Christian region. Uh
Egypt and greater Syria. So 30,000
churches and the holy sele destroyed. So
all of that and and the Christians of
Europe remembered that. So that's what
gave rise and led to the first crusade.
What was the draft like in the first
crusade? The draft. Yeah. Who was those
people? There was no draft. This was it
was unbridled enthusiasm and it was
women and children, peasants. You
couldn't stop them. They were so it's
it's actually considered one of today's
great mysteries because there were calls
to other crusades before that including
when that khif destroyed the seleure and
the 30,000 churches that too provoked a
lot of Christians in the west but
nothing came of it. But for some reason
when when Pope Urban called for this
one, it just it's known in history as
one of the most massive campaigns where
it was hundreds of thousands of just
peasants took off to the holy land. What
they were promised. Okay. So the they
were promised remission of sins. So if
you go and you die. Yeah. Interesting.
Yeah. They were promised remission of
sins. It was a pilgrimage. It was the
crusades were actually pilgrimages. So
Christians wanted to do and should do
pilgrimages to the Holy Land. And the
Crusade was seen as an armed pilgrimage.
So you're doing two things. You're going
to go and you're going to fight the
pagans and help Christians and liberate
the Holy Land. And you're going to do
the pilgrimage, which you should do.
Okay? So yeah, there were incentives of
course uh which was the the remission of
sins was the main big one. Uh but they
were also, if you look at the sources,
the people were really driven um just by
the actual events themselves. So we can
say yeah there was a theological
component that motivated them. There's
no doubt about that. But at the same
time it was really trying to redress all
these wrongs that I just described
because that comes out in the sources.
That's what really uh they preached.
Urban Peter the hermit and all these
other uh preachers and that's what
really drove the people to go on the
crusade. Any documented atrocity
atrocities from those people from the
crusades? Yeah, the main ones especially
you have different movements because it
wasn't a coherent force like I was
saying it was just people on their own
started going and um among among some of
them is you know they're known as the
peasant crusaders and so there were
leaderless peasants and you know the
main attacks was on Jews that happened
in Europe um you know right I think I
want to say maybe 1096 or right around
1097 around Germany and their logic you
know the the peasants would rile each
other up because they'd be traveling by
land on foot and they'd get tired and
they say, "Why are we going all the way
to fight the Muslim haters of Christ
when we have them right here in our own
land, the Jews?" And so they would
attack them and plunder them. But it's
notable to point out that the actual
authorities, the church, and even the
higher nobles would come against it.
They would condemn it and they would
actually uh try to defend the Jews and
they would sometimes even excommunicate
the Christians who did this. The the
great schism occurred in what year? I
think the the formal year uh it's in the
year 1000 something I don't know 1012 or
1094. So it's after the crusade. No it's
before before. It's before. So there was
Orthodox already and Catholics. Yeah.
The Catholics and the Orthodox as we
call them today always existed. But the
you know today Orthodox is big O and
Catholic is big C. But historically they
were both small O and both small C.
Catholic just meant universal. Orthodox
meant the straight way. Till today,
Catholics tell you we're the Orthodox
ones because we're the straight way and
the Orthodox tell you, no, we're the
universal church. So, you know, these
these terms, you know, they have their
traditional meaning and they have now
their big meaning. So, in total, there
were how many crusades? Eight. Uh yeah,
it depends on who you ask, but
traditional numbers nine. So, let's say
they didn't succeed. What kind of world
would we live in right now? Well, really
the only one that did succeed is the
first one that we're talking about and
it was essentially, you know, the the
actual conquests or reconquests that
they made were all nullified by 1291. So
by 1099, the crusaders a few years after
the first crusade is called in 1095,
they've achieved their goal. They've
liberated the Holy Land. Jerusalem is
under Christian, Latin, Frankish
control, as well as other cities. And
they stayed there. Yeah, they stayed
there. They liberated Antioch, Adessa,
you know, Tripoli, various other areas.
And they stayed there and they continued
fighting the Muslims until 1291. So
almost 200 years. And by 1291, that's
when basically they're completely
eliminated and kicked out of the Holy
Land. So let's say they didn't succeed
in the first crusade. What kind of world
would we live in right now?
I would say not much different because
because the the actual um benefits that
they accured were all nullified. So
we're we're sort of back to where we
started. You know, they conquered it and
they lost it. So they never had it. In
other words, we are today where we were
before they conquered it. It was still
Muslim territory. So Muslims would not
conquer Europe. I wouldn't speak Arabic
right now. Muslims wouldn't speak
Arabic. No, they wouldn't conquer Europe
if not the Crusades. Or would they? So
before the crusades, the Muslims
conquered all of North Africa and the
Middle East and Spain and they went into
Europe and stopped at Tours in 732 and
they continued attacking Europe and then
you have the Crusades which is kind of
different because now it's it's the
Europeans are striking back and going to
the Muslim lands in the Holy Land and
you know that's what preoccupies Muslims
and Christians for two centuries then
they lose. Then the Muslims continue
what they had started which was
attacking the Christian world. So they
had conquered Spain and that's still
going on. You have the reconista but now
you have the rise of the Ottoman Turks.
So after the Seljic Turks who were the
primary um antagonists of the f of the
crusades, you have the another group of
Turks who are known as the Ottomans and
now they become the new attackers of
Europe which is after the crusades. So
1291's end of the crusades, right around
1300 is the rise of the Ottomans and
it's late 1300s now they're entering
into Europe and conquering the Balkans.
Um and then by 1453 very famously
Constantinople was conquered. Why did
Europe stay Christian? Who stopped the
uh the Islam? Who stopped the Muslims?
Yes. The Christians of Europe. They
fought back all the for centuries. Yeah.
Back and forth. Back and forth. So um so
from let's you know the crusades are
over 1291 1300s and all throughout the
1300s the Turks start invading Europe
okay and the Christians of Europe all of
whom are at this point Catholic or
orthodox because no Protestant
Reformation yet fight back and um you
have some of the most you know wild war
battles during this time of course a lot
of them are actually in defenders of the
west where I talk about John Hunyadi and
Scanderbeg of Albania and Vlad Vladepus
Vlad the inv you know the impaler this
is all in the 15th century right before
the Protestant Reformation um and they
all fight back and that's and they and
to them to the Christians of the time
they saw it as a civilizational conflict
that they had to do this otherwise they
know what Islam has been doing it's been
swallowing up so much of Christendom for
centuries they knew and understood that
North Africa Egypt all the way to
Morocco and Syria and Asia Minor you
know only recently all Christian
regions. Asia Minor is where most of St.
Paul's epistles were into, you know,
that's how Christian it was. They knew
that that was all conquered and
swallowed up by Islam and they are next,
you know. So it was it was a very
existential life and death struggle. So
at that time Europe is fighting Islam
and the Muslims and at the same time
they're fighting each other, right? So
100 years old war between France and
England, etc. At the same time, what's
happening in the Middle East? Are
Muslims fighting each other as well?
Yeah, they are. It's the same sort of
thing. Um at during this time the two
primary powers of the Muslim world are
the Ottomans in Turkey and the Mamluks.
The Mamluks and it's just an Arabic word
means he who is owned a slave. Mamluks
were again more Turkish or Circatian
uh tribesmen who were imported Islamized
became slave soldiers but then they got
too powerful and they and they actually
overthrew the Muslims who had imported
them and they became the new rulers and
their head and their headquarters was in
Egypt. So the Turks the Ottomans were in
Turkey as we know it and the Mamlukes
were primarily in Egypt and also in
Syria as well. Um, and they fought until
1517 when the Ottomans actually
conquered them and absorbed their lands
as well. And those wars had nothing to
do with the Shia and Sunnis. No, the
Mluks and the Ottomans were both Sunnis,
but you did have the Shia in Iran also
during this time. And in fact, I believe
the Ottomans as part of their pretext in
their war in the Mluks was because the
Mluks were supposedly helping the Shia
of Iran against the Ottomans. So yeah,
the Shia thing was always there. But
these, excuse me, these particular wars
that I just mentioned, the the main two
powers were both Sunnis. So you know
what's interesting? So Christianity has
Orthodox, Protestants and Cathol
Catholics, right? And Muslims, Islam has
Shia and Sunnis. We don't fight each
other. They do till this day why
why don't Catholics and Protestants and
Orthodox not fight? And why do Sunnis
and Shia fight? Yeah. Well, I would
argue um yeah, obviously in in the west
they don't fight anymore. And some
people will tell you that's because all
of them have lost their uh you know
their zeal and that's why in other words
it's because of a more secularist
atmosphere that all Christians Catholic,
Protestant, Orthodox are able to
coexist, which is fine. Um I would Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Um in other words, I'm I'm
trying to say it's not necessarily
because they've lost their zeal. It's
just because they've lived, you know,
they can tolerate each other. So that's
good. Um the Sunnis and Shia actually by
and large what happens with the Sunnis
and Shia is when they have conflicts
with the greater infidel world
Christians let's say they actually
either ally or they at least leave each
other alone. It's only when they don't
have that kind of problem that they
start fighting with each other. Right.
But they are fighting each other just
because simply because of the
inheritage. Yeah. Yeah, the orig the
origin of uh the Sunni Shia rift
ironically is it has to do with who is
going to be the successor of Muhammad.
So the the Shia believe that whoever
khalif means successor. So the khalif
must be a descendant of Muhammad
specifically through his only surviving
daughter Fatima and his first cousin Ali
and they have Hassan and Hussein. So
their descendants must be the leaders of
the Islamic world. That's the Shia view.
That's the minority view. the Sunni view
is essentially you know obviously
doesn't have to be a descendant of uh so
anyway it starts off that way and that
they start waring after the battle of
Carbala in 680 um but but now they're
very much different even theologically
so because of all these centuries you
know almost 14 centuries um so even now
theologically the Shia are very much
more mystical their religion has
branched off as opposed to Sunniism it's
funny because a lot of people you know
we think of Iran is the great enemy and
but it's a Shia nation really the
radical problematic Muslims are all
Sunnis so if you look at even the
terrorist groups al-Qaeda ISIS Boo Haram
al-Shab Hamas these are all Sunni
organizations and it makes sense because
Sunnis are the majority okay they're 90%
of the the Islamic world but also their
theology so Saudi Arabia is our friend
but its theology is much more violent
than Shia Islam who's our enemy So
obviously there's a political dimension
here as well that transcends the actual
religious aspect. So khalif is a su
successor. Successor. Yeah. What's a
caliphate? The Arabic is a khalif and a
khalifa and caliphate. Caliphate is
basically a system of governance based
on a khalif. So it's it's the rule of a
khalif. A caliphate. What's a jihad?
Because when I was doing a podcast with
the imam, he said that jihad is like the
way of some kind of to protest jihad to
do something, right? Yeah. But what we
know jihad is they say always the holy
war. The holy war about against the
non-believers. Holy war is an old
English translation of jihad which is
perfectly suitable because it is exactly
that is what jihad is. The game that
some Muslim apologists play is they say
that uh the word jihad means to struggle
and that we as Muslims are supposed to
struggle uh to bring Islam in, you know,
to whatever in a good way. That's what
they say. We're struggling for to help
empower Islam. Okay. Well, historically
that was done through violence. So jihad
meant holy war. So if a Muslim said,
"I'm doing jihad," he meant, "I'm
attacking the keer, the infidel, through
violence." So that's what it meant
historically for centuries. But what's
funny is, you know, they they the
apologetic game where they tell you um
jihad means struggle. It actually
underscores how the issue of jihad is
even worse than we thought because it's
true. It means to struggle. It does not
mean physical struggle only. That has
been its primary manifestation. But it
does mean that Muslims must struggle in
all ways to help empower and make Islam
supreme. And so until today you have
Islamic scholars who talk about the
jihad, they have different names. I'll
just give you the English translation,
but jihad of the pen, jihad of the
tongue, jihad of the money, jihad of the
womb, and all of them are to serve Islam
to empower it over infidels. So jihad of
the pen means propaganda. So so does
jihad of the tongue, which means lying.
You know, say whatever you have to say
to help Islam look good or to demoralize
non-Muslims. Okay. Uh, the money jihad
means you fund the jihad. I'm a rich
Saudi. Okay, I don't have to commit. I'm
not going to fight, but I'm going to
send them millions. Okay, jihad of the
womb means I'm going to help the cause
by having as many children as possible.
All the Muslims. All right? And they
actually say this all the time. This is
happening in Europe. This is one of the
jihads. So, yes, jihad as an Arabic word
simply means to struggle on behalf of
Islam. But that doesn't make it better.
It actually makes it worse. its primary
um manifestation historically was
through force, but as I just described,
it has other ways that it's being done
too as well now. So, Islam is a
religion. What's an Islamism?
That's a good question. Um, Islamism is
a way for a lot of modern Western
commentators to try to
distance Islam from the bad things about
Islam. So, it's a way of trying to say
Islam as a religion is okay. It's the
bad stuff that people do, the terrorism,
you know, the jihad and all that. That's
Islamism. It's sort of an academic
distinction. I think there's a it has it
has a political correct aspect to it.
Rather than say Islam and offend all the
Muslims of the world, you pretend that
it's a specific ideology. Okay? But at
the same time, it it has some merit
because uh you know, the stuff that
modern-day Muslims who are radicals or
whatever promote sometimes is a slightly
different from traditional Islam. It's
they're both they're both still violent
and intolerant towards non-Muslims, but
it almost has a western influence to it.
So I think it's okay to use the word
Islamism because it's it's its own
unique sort of thing which is
anacronistic if you want to compare it
to historic Islam. Okay. But long story
short either way whether it's Islam or
Islamism they all trace back to the
teachings of Islam primarily. Why do you
think there are the countries of the
Muslim countries differ so much from
each other? let's say Saudi Arabia, UAE
are much way more different than I would
say especially now Syria or Iran,
Pakistan. Why do you think there is such
a difference between them? Well, you you
can't discount the the cultural and
national differences, you know. So,
before Islam, Pakistan, they're Hindus
and um Arabia they're Arabs and um you
have Indonesians, you have Turks. So,
they all have their own culture. A lot
of them have their own languages. Um,
and you know that that comes out. So
even though they're all Muslims, still
at the same time they have their own
national characteristics and it becomes
sort of a blend. Their Islam blends in
with their particular culture and their
language. So you you you know it's still
it's still part of that human element,
you know, that still is alive regardless
of the religious dynamic. So we're
saying right now, so we're being told uh
especially by the news outlets and etc
that Iran is the our enemy, right? Iran
is the enemy of the west. But Iran, they
are not Arabs, they're Persians and they
were not Muslims. They were conquered.
Mhm. So I was having this Uber drive, I
want to say, let's say two months ago.
And the guy was from Iran and he
migrated here, I want to say five to
seven years ago. And he told me that
people in Iran, they don't like Islam at
all. they don't like this radical
religion of theirs because it was
imposed to them and he was saying that
it was it's just a matter of time when
they do a revolution and that Iran is
not going to be a Muslim country. What
are your thoughts on that? I largely
agree. A lot of the Persian people
themselves. Uh when we think of Iran, we
think of the mullas and we think of this
Islamic Republic and they're all, you
know, radical Muslims. It's called the
Islamic Republic of Iran. It's it is a
theocracy essentially. But ironically,
the people are not. The people are very
much fed up with it and they're actually
very westernized. Historically, if you
looked at the Muslim nations, Persia was
by far one of the most westernized
nations much more than Egypt and of
course Saudi Arabia and all these
countries, Syria, Lebanon, Persia was
the one because like you said, they
maintained their culture, their
language. Um, you know, Egypt had its
own language, Syria had its own
language. all these lang the countries
that we call Arab world Arab it's
because they all speak Arabic now but
they actually had their own language and
it's now been suppressed to their credit
places like Persia kept it managed to
maintain their cultural identity and I
think it still lives on still so yeah
the people of of Iran despite the image
we have are actually largely very
secular and western oriented it's just
the regime that holds them together and
that which many of them hate but the
regime that regime is pretty new, right?
Since 1979. Prior to that, that was Sha.
Prior to Sha, what was Iran like? Yeah,
it was still, you know, Sha, we're
talking in the 70s. So, even before
that, you
know, usually Adatururk, who's the Turk,
you know, and he was he was the first
one to really start reforming. And this
is way back in, I think, the 30s or
maybe 20s. So, it was still it was like
the Sha. In fact, it was, I believe, his
father. And he he was also very secular
and westward looking basically the um
and remember Persia even dur the Ottoman
Empire is what the west dealt with
during the colonial era but Persia
wasn't it was it was its own u you know
Shia manifestation and it was again very
secularized and became very it was one
of the most secular western looking
nations and for a long time even before
the sha and um the rise of the Ayatollah
Kumeni and the Islamic Republic public
was sort of a backlash and it was a sort
of you know it was because it was
getting too western overly western. So
this was a sort of conservative
reactionary movement but I think since
then a lot of um the Persians actually
regret it. So I see from from time to
time I see uh sayings like uh Christian
Christians are the true colonizers right
they colonize the entire world
especially North America, South America
etc. But at the same time, Muslims are
not. Is it true? Absolutely not. Uh the
only the only reason people get away
with this argument is they um present it
in a vacuum. In other words, and I see
this all the time. I'll give you an
example. Um I wrote the book Sword and
Scimitar, 14 centuries of war between
Islam and the West. So what do I do?
Thanks. I is basically I talk about
every century and what was happening
between the West and Islam. Today what
people do, so I'll give you a perfect
example. There's a book that came out
the same year that book came out and I
know this because my my literary agent
told me and he thought it would be a
competitor book. It was by some
professor at Georgetown and it was
called um Jihad and Crusade, the
thousand-year struggle between something
like the North and the South. If you
look at that book, it's maybe 700 pages.
It's humongous. And it's about the
thousand-year war. But guess what? From
the very beginning of the conflict, the
time of Muhammad until 1800, it gets 30
pages. Okay. Interesting. Yeah. And then
the last 200 gets the whole book. So
what's the difference? What happened?
The last 200 years is when actually u so
the beginning the years that get 30
pages which in my book are the main
pages is when Islam is attacking and
conquering and colonizing Christian
territory. Okay. So that's completely
ignored. And then if you look at the
true history as I describe it around
1800 finally Europe which was always at
the receiving end and being attacked and
was the weak one against the against the
Muslim empires especially the Ottoman
Empire finally it's reversed. Now
they're strong and the Muslims are weak
and now the Christians start invading
North Africa and the Middle East etc.
and they start colonizing it. So what
people do now is they ignore the whole,
you know, 90% of the history when it was
the opposite and they out of they
pretend everything was fine until Europe
started doing this. They're the bad
guys. Okay? And even that colonization
itself was a reflection and a reaction
to the perennial thousand-year jihad. If
you look at what the French and the
British how they thought they were going
into these lands because they knew these
were the violent hostile Muslim lands
that had conquered and attacked
Christians and western civilization and
they wanted to put an end to it. So it
it was itself was a reaction to what
Muslims had been doing for centuries
against the west. But today the
narrative that you're mentioning you
know Christians are the bad guys not
Muslims is because they completely omit
and ignore the bulk of history. So the
book I'm telling you ignores, you know,
the first thousand years and then the
last 200 years it just sits and dwells
that oh the horrible Europeans look they
conquered this region and Muslims are
still agrieved about it and it makes
sense if you don't know the actual
history.
Okay, I got it. Uh Sharia law is it
mentioned in the Quran and what is it?
What's Yeah, I don't know if it's
mentioned in the Quran. Sharia is a word
which like a lot of Islamic words it
means the the pathway to the water well.
Okay. Because people in Arabia are
living in a desert and Sharia or Shada
means the roadway to life water. So in
Islamic usage and terminology it becomes
the road to life. Okay which is
basically or we can translate it Islamic
law which is what Muslims must do to be
good Muslims. It's the pathway to life.
That's what Sharia means. And it's
essentially um it's laws. So Islamic law
is a very legitimate and fair
translation. And it's laws that are
based on the Quran. The the twin pillars
are usually seen as the Quran and the
Sunnah which is the Hadith and the S.
And whatever Muslims think are real,
reliable, authentic teachings by
Muhammad as derived from the Sunnah. And
based on that and some other things like
is means you know whatever the consensus
is. If there's some controversial issue
what do or the scholars believe that's
also and they use something called kas
which means analogy. So for example uh
you know Islamic law doesn't talk about
smoking but it does say don't drink and
because that means don't harm yourself.
So smoking is also not necessarily
haram. It's makru which means disliked.
Anyway it's it's pretty convoluted but
that's all what it is. It's Islamic law.
But they're having right now Sharia
trials in Europe. Is that correct?
Sharia trials. Yeah. I don't know. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yes. Yes. In
places in Europe, because they have such
a large Muslim population, they're
giving in and allowing Islamic law to
trump native law of Europe, wherever
Muslims are in the name of
multiculturalism and diversity and etc.
So yeah, from what I understand in
various Muslim heavy regions in I think
England especially, they actually have
what amounts to Sharia law for Muslims
to actually um to for Muslim it's not
it's for Muslims to judge themselves
against each other. So they allow them
to do it through their own courts. So
we're in the year 2025. Where do you
think we are at right now? Especially
Europe in regards to Islam. Islam trying
to conquer Europe, conquer the western
society. Um well, I've looked at various
pew polls and they talk about the
demography. What interests me is the
demography um of the changing face of
Europe. Mhm. I always say this, you
know, I find it very ironic, but most
Western people, you know, they think
they're very unfortunately they're very
centric. They just think of their own
civilization. So they look at the west,
they look at America, they look at
Europe, and they still see the minority
are the majority are still white people,
including in Europe. They don't realize
though that white people are like about
4% of the world population. So they're a
very tiny tiny minority. 4%. Yeah. Look
it up. It's something like that. Uh of
the world. I mean, just think about it.
it just the Indians alone I think are
two billion and the Chinese are like two
billion and then and the Africans and
yeah so it's a very small minority and I
just I always I marvel that it is this
tiny minority that feels incumbent upon
itself to bring everyone into its land
and to suppress its own culture and its
own heritage and its own religion in the
name of diversity and it's just amazing
to me it's a sort of suicide no other
country no other civilization does And
rightfully so. Why should they? Okay.
But I don't know why Europeans feel the
need to just flood their lands with
especially when they are such a tiny
minority to start with. You have no
explanation to this. No, no, I do have
an explanation. The explanation is um
well, it's very convoluted, but you know
the the easy explanation is the leaders
of Europe are intentionally doing this.
whether it's because they're just
ideologically compromised or stupid or
whether there's an agenda which is
against their own people which may very
well be the case you know I mean in
England it's reached the point where you
can't even say the truth about what's
happening without going to jail and this
is amazing and this is supposed to be a
country so obviously the rulers of
England whether they are British natives
hate and are waring on their own people
it's just as clear as that there's no
other explanation But people can't wrap
their minds around that. Or in other
areas, they keep bringing importing more
and more Muslim migrants and all you see
is more and more violence and
criminality and they just and if you
talk about it, you get arrested. So,
okay. So, if the people of Europe see
this, and maybe they do or they don't,
but they're not doing anything about it,
they've been very much emasculated and
paralyzed, handicapped. And so what's
happening today, if this was happening
to the ancestors, the defenders of the
west that I write about, they would have
gone to war a long time ago. And you
crusade of course against their own
people, the leaders. But today's uh
Europeans are not going to do that. But
Europe is being co conquered right now
by soft soft power, not the hard power.
Exactly. That's genius. Of course, you
don't even have to go to war. They let
them in. Yeah. Exactly. You know, the
history of Europe has been fighting
tooth and nail against Islam to keep it
out and killing and sacrificing
themselves. And now after finally
winning, they go out of their way to
bring them in. And um the Muslims that
are being brought in, a lot of them are
still behaving in the old way,
violently, criminal criminality. So it's
amazing, you know, uh it's suicidal.
What other way can I explain it, you
know? So let's take west and east. West
let's say Europe and maybe then North
America in the age of cent 19th to 20th
century why does why do almost all the
inventions come from the western
civilization not from the eastern we we
got mathematics come from came from
Arabs right some something came from
China but it's like you can count it on
fingers on on your both hands why there
I want to say 90% of all the inventions
from the west not from the east does it
correct relate with religion. Yeah.
Well, so the the the western narrative
would be because once religion in in
Europe was sort of sidelined and
secularism was allowed to breathe,
science could develop and people were no
longer afraid of being called heretics
or blasphemers because they, you know,
they give you the stories about
Capernacus and, you know, the earth and
the shape of it and the sun, what goes
around what and if you said the wrong
thing, you could get in trouble with
church authorities. So that that's a
traditional narrative of why in the west
science and technology has progressed um
because the shackles of religion were no
longer there to to to oppress people and
they could think freely. That's the
traditional narrative. Um whereas in the
Islamic
world for example you definitely don't
have that. Um there's this famous saying
which is the doors of Ishtahed which
means the doors of uh free
interpretation were closed like in the
year 1100 and everything in Islamic
world became very wooden and literal and
you couldn't and if you actually try to
break through that mold you're a heretic
so just accept the world as it is don't
think about it you know that sort of
thing so that's the general um narrative
of why it succeeded but I would argue
that Christianity itself uh fosters and
allow that. So the other argument is it
actually succeeded in the west because
the west was Christian and Christianity
actually lays the seed and allows
science to vent. There's nothing in
Christ's teaching that says you can't
you know think and and be engage in
scientific methodology for example. So I
think that is also why it rose and if
you look at all it's not even just um
science and technology if you just look
at progress governance freedom um ethics
morality it came from Christian nations
you know and
uh why it wasn't from confus it wasn't
from China it wasn't from the Islamic
world the stuff that the whole world
wants and this is why they moved to the
west progress and technology and
enlightenment and freedom it all was
from Christian lands. It didn't grow in
other lands, Muslim or Confucian or
Hindu. There's a reason for that. Yeah.
But it's like every aspect of of the
world, right? Music, Western
civilization, movies, art, like almost
everything. Of course, you've got great
art in the Middle East, but almost no
music. No,
music is bad according to even art is
bad. You can't have representations. Um,
it's haram. So is music. You can't
represent Muhammad and the Allah. Well,
that not yes, but you're not also
representing anything. Drawing a human
is considered idolatry. It's like I'm
worshiping the human. So that's why if
you really look at Islamic art, it's
limited to patterns, you know. It's you
never So this would be an idolatry. This
right here. Yes. Oh yeah, of course.
Yeah. Yeah. This is total idolatry to
Muslims
and the frescas in Italy as well. Yeah.
Oh yeah. This is why when they conquered
Constantinople for example or hag Sophia
they covered and painted over all some
of them have been actually able to be
refurbished and brought back but the
frescos and the icons and a lot of them
were destroyed ritually hypothetically
let's if you take away all the oil from
Middle East would it be as successful as
it is right now of course not if you
took away all the oil from the Middle
East Islam would not be a problem is a
problem primarily ly because of oil
wealth, because all of what we call
radicalization and dissemination of
radical jihadist literature and the
support of radical mosques and satellite
stations is all entirely funded by oil
wealth from Saudi Arabia and the other
Gulf nations entirely. And if they
didn't have that
wealth, what you know, what we call rad
Islam would be such a weak thing right
now. But it's being betressed and
supported and spearheaded entirely by
the many many billions of dollars that
come just from oil. But it's just a
matter of time when it ends. Yeah,
depending on who you ask. Um, you know,
it could be 50 years or 100 years and
and who knows what will happen in the
meantime. Um, but yeah, it should end,
but it could have ended a long time ago.
The people who found the oil in Arabia
were western people, you know, and uh at
the time the Arabs were living like
Muhammad in tents in bedawinds and in,
you know, in the time of Saudi Arabia.
They didn't even find it. I think
there's a good cause and a good argument
that Europeans and Westerners or the
whole world can appropriate and take the
oil and let and let the Arabs go back to
the way they were living, which is
according to true Sharia. In fact, the
wealth has corrupted the Arabs because
they're not living according to the
Sunnah of Muhammad who lived in the
desert. They're multi-millionaires who
live in live lavish par, you know. So,
do them a favor. You take away that
money and so it doesn't support all this
jihadist ideology that's being
disseminated around the world. Yeah. But
with all that money, they build
incredible cities like Dubai, right? And
you can be a Christian, you can be a
Jew, and you can live in Dubai. But at
the same time they're saying that this
is still a Muslim country but you you as
a Muslim are not allowed to drink
alcohol but there's still alcohol or
cigarettes tobac tobacco tobacco in that
city. Yeah. Yeah. But these are tiny
tiny countries. When I think of oil I'm
thinking of Arabia and in that country
you can't even not only can you not have
a church if you if Christians laborers
Filipinos meet in a or Indonesians or
whatever and they meet in a house and
try to celebrate Christmas they get
arrested and tortured. Okay. So that's
the primary um yeah but I know Qatar and
Dubai and these places are seen as you
know western friendly and they are but
they're very very tiny and uninfluential
in that sense. It's the really the heart
of it all is Arabia, Saudi Arabia. So so
Christians have uh the Bible, right?
It's the holy book. So uh Protestants
have 66 books in the Bible. Uh Catholics
and and Orthodox
73 books. Mhm. Yeah. The Deuteronom
Yeah. the extra duter or as they're
called apocrypha books. Yeah. So,
Muslims have the Quran. Jews have what?
They have the the Old Testament, but
they call it the Pentatuk, the Tanak.
Yeah. What's the Talmud?
The Talmud is um as I understand it, um
which comes much later after the
diaspora and the destruction of the
second temple. And it's these uh it's
these rabbitical writings and jeritical
writings um uh about you know that arose
in the in the circumstances of Jews now
living in exile because now it's with
the destruction as I understand of
second temple Judaism itself is
destroyed because you need the temple to
do sacrifices. Yeah. I mean that's the
understanding of traditional Judaism.
And so with the destruction, Judaism
sort of I don't know if I want to use
the word, but it's in a transitional
phase or a temporary phase. And I
believe that's the origin of the Talmud,
which is basically dealing with and
responding to new circumstances that
were not that are not covered in the
context of having a temple, for example.
But not all Jews live according to the
Talmud. I don't believe so. No. So we're
Christians, right? So we live and we are
waiting for the second coming of Jesus
Christ. In the meantime we uh have kids
and love our neighbors and etc. Right?
So Muslims are waiting for the second
coming of Jesus as well. Is that
correct? No, they're not waiting for the
second coming of Jesus. He's just he's
just a part of the second coming. But
he's not the culmination of the second
coming. Um, you know, there's, you know,
you have the war, you have the war with
the de, okay, where I think even Jesus
fights this, which we would call an
antichrist figure, something like that.
Um, and depending on if it's a Sunni or
Shia, um, esquetology, endday
understanding, they differ as well. Um,
but yeah, Jesus has a role, but it's not
about Jesus. In the Christian
understanding, Jesus is coming to rule
and judge. In the Muslim understanding,
yes, because they're trying to maintain
that, they're trying to stick to the
original narrative so they can seem
legitimate. He's still part of it. But
the reality, but the it just ends up
with everyone being judged according to
the teachings of Muhammad. Okay? But if
let's say we're you, you and me, we are
Jews. So we are not waiting for Christ
because he we know that he he he lived.
He's not a prophet. He's nobody to us.
So, we're waiting for the Messiah that
will build the third temple, right? So,
we could do sacrifices because now we're
sinners, right? Right. So, the third
temple has to be built on that mount.
Mhm. Only on that mount, no other place.
I'm not entirely sure, but that's what
my understanding. And you cannot build
the third temple because there is a
mosque underneath it. Yeah. Or Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So, Christians and Muslims are friends
for or foes. Christians and Muslims,
are they friends or foes to each other?
Yes. You mean if you're a Christian
doctrinally, historically,
contemporarily? Okay. To a Muslim, a
Christian is a foe because he's a
non-Muslim. Okay. Islam, the the
teachings are, you know, the word keer.
Okay. Okay, the word kefir means um if
you look at a Quran today and they
translate it generally as unbeliever. So
today they'll tell you ker means
non-Muslim. All right. Um and that is
what it means. But the word itself is so
full of negative connotations. Okay. To
be a keer is to essentially be an enemy
of Islam, an enemy of Allah, an enemy of
Muslims. You're like an animal. You're
described as being a dumb brute cow
beast. Okay. um God wants to torture and
terrorize you. So it's interesting
because you read a English Quran
translation and you just see the word
unbeliever and you think it's neutral,
you know, but it actually it's so full
of these negative negative connotations.
So I only bring that up because you're
asking me, you know, Christians and Jews
or Christians and Muslims, are they
friends? Well, from the Muslim point of
view, if you read the Quran, if you read
the Sunnah and the Hadith, no, they're
not. Christians are enemies. So are
Jews. So is everyone who's not a Muslim.
You know, I I have a video I translated
I put on I put it on my or my YouTube a
long long time ago of an Egyptian cleric
saying how, you know, Islamic law allows
a Muslim man to marry a Christian woman
or a Jewish
woman. But he says you have to hate her
because Islam teaches you have to hate
non-Muslims. So even if you're married
to this woman who's a Christian or Jew,
you can copulate with her and um you
know treat her as your wife, but you
have to hate her and show her that you
hate her. Okay? But once she converts,
she says that Muhammad is the Sure. Of
course, if she converts, then she's
good. You can love her. But as long as
she doesn't, you can marry her and you
can engage in sexual relations with her,
but you have to hate her. Yeah. But why
is that just one man saying? If it's not
mentioned the same. No, no. But his
saying, it's not just one man saying.
It's an actual teaching and it comes
from the Quran. The verse that I told
you for example that uh it's Quran 64
which says the example for you as a
Muslim is Abraham and he said to his
family I hate you until you become
Muslims. So that's the that's the
pivotal verse. So to Christians Muslims
are friends or foes to well historically
to Christians Muslims were people who
attacked them and stole their nations
and conquered their land. Right now
you're a Christian if you meet a Muslim
he's a friend or foe to you. uh to me
virus. Um so he's an individual human
being who can have his own thoughts and
his own beliefs but I know the ideology
that he is formally associated with
Islam is hostile to me and hostile to my
beliefs. I don't know to what to what
degree he is aligned with this and this
is why you get moderate Muslims who you
know they call themselves Muslims but
they're good people and they don't think
these things. Yeah. And they don't think
these things. I get it. Okay. Um, but
that's, you know, but I don't know how
they
reconcile, you know, I as a Christian
can reconcile my beliefs with my Bible
because it's not telling me to go
conquer and kill. Okay? I don't know how
they reconcile their peaceful beliefs,
which I believe are true. Um, but their
book says otherwise. But that's also not
that hard to understand. Today, we live
in a day and age where you have
Christians and priests and pastors who
believe that homosexuality is okay, even
though the Bible goes out of its way to
condemn it. Old and New Testament. So
people can believe whatever they want
and they can associate themselves with
the religion, but the religion is what
the religion is. Why are you a
Christian? Why am I a Christian? Well, I
would probably be a Christian because I
was born into it. That's the main
reason, but I'm also convinced by it.
the actual uh I mean I've taken the time
to study and look into it and uh it's
it's makes you know it's the one it's
the most satisfying and intellectually
satisfying and not just intellectually
but it's the one that makes the most
sense to me. Is it fair to say that most
of Muslims are Muslim just because they
were born in the Middle East? I would
argue most people are whatever religion
they are because they were born into it.
Most people, you know, converts whether
it's a atheist or a Muslim who converts
to Christianity or a Christian or an
atheist who converts to Islam are very
very rare. Most people are actually in
the religion that they were born into.
Is there anything that you don't like
about the Christianity?
Well, I I would have to ask you which
Christianity. Christianity, let's say
Bible only 66 biblical book. Yeah. Yeah.
the Christianity if you look at the look
there's always what we call hard sayings
you know when you read the Bible and
just things that kind of don't make
sense or seem strange
uh you know people will point to all
sorts of things especially in the Old
Testament where I forget you know which
prophet is it who who came out and all
these children mocked him because he was
bald and so God had a bear come out and
killed them all or something like that
so there's all the always these things
that you come across in the Bible which
you know raise questions and they're
known as you know hard sayings and you
know as everyone else I counter them and
I try to figure them out and you know
try to rationalize them away but by and
large the the religion itself and its
actual teachings the central core
tenants which should really matter
especially from a metaphysical point of
view I believe are very uh you know
appealing and authentic to me. So when
people say that you have so you're a
Christian right you believe in the Bible
you have to believe everything that is
written in the Bible and for instance
they take a few verses from the
Deuteronomy or Leviticus you have to
stone gays adulterers and etc. And I'm
always saying that's why you have to
read the whole Bible especially the New
Testament because when Jesus was born
and he's teaching he says love your
neighbor what are the most important two
commandments right love your God and
love your neighbor like yourself. So it
means that you don't have to stone gays
adulterers and etc from now on since
Jesus has arrived. Yeah. Well that's why
it's called the old and the new
testament. There's a new covenant. The
old is you know the one that would still
govern the ancient Hebrews. you know
that's that's how they lived and you
know according to Christian teaching
that was what God wanted uh but it's
also understood you know that that was
the time and place that that sort of
thing happened but Jesus comes and a lot
of it you know the spirit of it is still
the same so homosexuality is still bad
for example but now you don't have to
stone them okay it's not for you to do
that let's say but it so in that sense
it hasn't changed you know the sins are
still the sins but uh now there's this
new covenant where you there's
forgiveness, there's there's um, you
know, tolerance, which doesn't mean you
should accept it. Of course, I think
it's still outlawed. You know, Paul
makes that very clear. It's an
abomination. It's one of the Romans very
clearly, you know, discusses sexual
immorality and homosexuality. So, in
that sense, I don't think the New
Testament and the Old Testament differ
much. It's just about, you know, the the
punishments and the consequences. So,
right is still right and wrong is still
wrong. Um, is there anything that you
like about Islam? that I like about
Islam. Yeah. I like the fact in Islam
it's it's conservative and it's
traditional. you know uh the stuff that
we are suffering from in western
civilization which is you know gender
confusion uh this you know wild rampant
feminism this emasculation of men etc
etc which is very much I think being
enforced on western peoples many of whom
are Christian at least in their
background you know that's I think
that's very despicable and to Muslims
credit they don't really suffer from
that sort of thing so I give them that
that's a good thing that doesn't
necessarily really you know that's not a
reflection of their pure theology. I
think a lot of it is actually more
cultural and has to do you know with
them being such oldworld people who but
if you bring a Muslim and you put them
in the west for a few generations they
become the same. So they also get
watered down. So I think it's not it's
less a reflection of Islam and less a
reflection of Christianity and more to
do with you know these cultural and
societal forces that are impacting both
groups. Would you say more Christians uh
convert to Islam or more Muslims convert
to Christianity? Ah, that's a good
question. Um, you know, if I had to
think about it and from what I've seen,
I would I would argue more Muslims
convert to Christianity. Uh because I
follow a lot of Arabic media and I watch
a lot of these shows. Um uh and the
Christians who convert to to Islam, you
know, they're usually limited to Europe
and they're disaffected with sort of
this western
emasculization. A lot of them are in
prison in in you know African-Americans
in prison. A lot of them come out Muslim
for some reason. Um so I think you know
amongst Westerners the only appeal is
what I said which is it's more of a
masculine religion. Um, but spiritually
when I watch a lot of these shows and
I've seen Muslims complaining about how
many millions of Christians are how many
millions of Muslims are converting to
Christianity um because of a lot of you
know these pmical attacks on the
religion of Muhammad. So it's really
hard to say but I do know I've heard for
a fact Muslim clerks complaining about
millions of Muslims converted to
Christianity over the years whereas I
really don't know the number of um you
know European converts. I'm sure it's up
there, but I don't know about many
millions. If nothing changes political
wise in Europe, where do you see Europe
in 2050?
Well, it's funny you mentioned that
number because I believe I saw a Pew
poll that said in 2050, something like
Germany might be 40% Muslim. Okay. Yeah.
It's amazing like if nothing changes and
the birth rate of Muslims and this
ongoing immigration and the fact that
the Germans and Europeans in general
have a low birth rate, very low. Yeah.
So, um, and this is what Muslims
themselves call it's a demographic
jihad, the jihad of the womb, which I
mentioned, which is we're just going to
take over by, you know, outnumbering you
and procreating. And then the state pays
for it. you know the pays for all these
children that are you know you know the
name Muhammad is the number one name in
various European cities which is just
imagine what other civilization imagine
like in in in Mecca in Medina and in
Cairo the number one name is John that
is so inconceivable or even in in in
India or in Hong Kong but in the western
world yeah are you afraid of Islam
generally ah well That's what
Islamophobia means, right? Fear of
Islam. Yeah, I suppose I would be afraid
of Islam if uh who I am was thrown into
the midst of Muslims. Um but I don't
necessarily fear it in that sense. U
because I try not to put myself in that
situation. But um I'm wary of Islam
obviously because I know what it teaches
and how it feels about people like me
who are non-Muslims. So Islamophobia,
the irony about it is it's supposed to
be the word phobia, Greek word phobia
which means fear. Whenever people label
someone having a phobia, they mean it's
an irrational fear, right? So he's
claustrophobia, right? Or a gorophobia.
He's afraid of being in a public space,
but it's irrational. In the case of
Islam, yeah, it is is we are
Islamophobic. We do fear it. And it's
rational to fear Islam because Islam
makes clear that I'm the enemy. What
about other religions? Hinduism with all
their their gods like the gods of war,
Khali. Yeah, they have all that and
they're they would be considered from a
Christian point of view pagans and
polytheists, but I don't you know they
don't have a systematic uh theology of
warfare the way Islam does. Islam is
very unique in its in the sense all
religions have you know just wars in
Christianity other forms of warfare in
other religions but Islam is unique in
that it has this imperative holy war
jihad. It's the only religion that's
like that. How do you view when you see
those videos from uh Israel when Jews
spit on Christians? How do I feel? How
do you view it? Oh, how do I view it? Uh
anti-Christians. They're not those
particular Jews. And my understanding
thankfully is that they're the minority.
Uh but they're obviously hostile and
enemies to Christianity to Christians.
Although we we share the same uh Old
Testament, they don't care. Well, yeah.
Yeah, I mean we share the same Old
Testament, but you know, the
historically the divide between Jews and
Christians is is great. It revolves
around the person of Christ. Um, you
know, so they, in other words, the the
the theme and the thing that makes
Christians who they are is precisely
what Jews reject, right? You know,
Muslims accept Jesus, but like I said,
it's not the real Jesus. It's AI isa.
So, they just want to use the name so
they have some legitimacy. uh but then
they present a completely different
Jesus. Uh but of course historically no
there's no you there's no way around it
that Christians and Jews have been at
odds and it's on it revolves around the
person of Jesus. So the last two
questions since I know that we're
running out of time. So let's have two
assumptions with you. Assumption number
one is the president of the United
States of America is the most powerful
human being on planet earth. Assumption
number two is you become one. You become
the president of the US and you have
this secret service at your disposal.
They come to you and say Mr. President,
we we love you. Congratulations. We know
all the answers in the world. You ask
us, we give you an honest answer. What
would be your first question? And and
oh, so what question? In other words,
you're asking me what questions do I
have if I know I'm going to get an
absolutely honest answer. Correct. What
would be the first? I know you've got
lots of them.
The first question as president of the
United States.
Well, I I already I think I already know
the answer, but I would be
um who's really in control of America
and why or not just America and Europe.
Why are these nations doing everything
possible to hurt themselves whereas
every other nation works for itself and
helps itself and does what we would call
selfish things? For example, why is it
in in Europe that the name Muhammad is
the number one name whereas this would
never happen in another country? I'd be
curious to know the answer. more
compassionate than they are. That's the
end. No, but you said they tell me the
truth. That's the politically correct
answer. Yes. I want the truth. They just
wanted to They just want to destroy
themselves. God bless you, Raymond. So,
your books can be bought on Amazon.
Yeah. Yeah, you can get them at Amazon.
That's probably the easiest and I think
even the least expensive place to get
them. And you've got the YouTube
channel? Yeah. And I have the new
YouTube channel description below. Yeah.
Holy War. God bless you. Thank you
first. Thank you Apollo.